es una cara familiar encabezará el
departamento de justicia de eeuu
el presidente electo joe biden reveló
que nominará a merrick garland como
fiscal general el jurista de 68 años
sirve actualmente como juez en la corte
federal de apelaciones del distrito de
columbia tiene un historial moderado y
es visto por muchos como aquel que
reparará el departamento de justicia
fuertemente politizado bajo la
administración de trump pero garland es
más conocido como el hombre cuya
nominación a la corte suprema fue
bloqueada por los republicanos en 2016
el presidente barack obama lo escogió
para ocupar una silla en el alto
tribunal pero debido a que esto ocurrió
en los últimos ocho meses del mandato de
obama el líder de la mayoría republicana
en el senado mitch mcconnell se negó
durante ese tiempo a tramitar su
nombramiento el puesto fue finalmente
ocupado en 2017 por el candidato de
trump del gurú graduado en harvard
garland fue nombrado asistente del
fiscal general adjunto en 1993 procesos
grandes casos como el del atentado de
oklahoma en 1995 y el de los juegos
olímpicos de atlanta en 1996 en 1997 el
presidente bill clinton nombró
para la corte de apelaciones de
washington de la que se convirtió en
juez principal en 2013 si se confirma su
nombramiento garland intentará retos
inmediatos incluida la forma de abordar
los problemas urgentes de derechos
civiles y revisar las políticas
policiales a raíz de las protestas
masivas por las muertes de
afroamericanos bajo responsabilidad de
agentes del orden